is it a bird is it a plane no it's a
biological male in the fast lane
definitely not a bird francis you
disgusting bigger that is trans woman
leah thomas annihilating the competition
she finished 1.5 seconds ahead of her
nearest competitor as my father used to
say if you want something done exactly
leah thomas born william thomas was an
average swimmer who barely made it into
the top 500. however willie refused to
be oppressed by heteronormative
stereotypes like fair play yes leah
bravely came out as transgender in 2019
but kept her male genitalia because it's
hard to be a top athlete if you spend
one week out of the month crying and
stuffing your face with chocolate you'd
know about that indeed i do several
women have complained that she has
exposed her male genitals in the
changing room which just goes to show we
still have a long way to go before we
root out transphobia from society
exactly if a trans man came into a men's
toilet and got his min jab to use the
urinal you'd get a round of applause
from the lads particularly from the in
cells who'd never seen one before there
wouldn't be any of this screaming about
safe spaces because men are tolerant all
we care about is that you get your round
in and never ever ever talk about your
feelings even gay men would be like stop
being honest about how you feel that's
gay correct if you're going through
tough times do the decent thing and push
it down like the rest of us nowadays
there's only one situation when you can
cry in public paying for petrol
personally i think the trans movement
doesn't go far enough i'm looking
forward to next year's crafts where
people who identify as dogs perform
tricks and jump over fences like good
little boys to be honest i don't know
why people are campaigning this is great
for women's sports they finally become
interesting no one in the history of the
universe has ever given a single [ __ ]
about women swimming but now thanks to
leah we're all talking about it in the
interest of balance we should say that
leah thomas has denied allegations that
she has an unfair advantage yes i have
her official statement here these
[ __ ] need to stop whining and the
statement goes on to say if they don't
like it they can suck my dick
[Music]